The next question, my name is Sarab. I'm
a student and live in USA. I had a
question that I hope you can give the
answer. If God forgives everyone's sin,
what if a person do all good deeds but
at exchange only wants from God to
forgive
Satan? Is this wish acceptable? If not
then what the promise that God gives us
that he will accept any dua. The
question posed by Sarah is that if Allah
is going to accept every dua he's given
the promise. So if we do good deeds and
we tell Allah to forgivel will he
forgive? If he doesn't then Allah hasn't
kept his promise. Point number one
nowhere does Allah anywhere in the Quran
or any authentic hadith says that he
will accept all your dua. It is your
wrong concept. It's a misconception that
you have. What Allah says that if you
truly repent then Allah will forgive any
sin of yours. So however much big sin
you do, as long as you repent sincerely
with your heart, Allah will forgive. So
that's the reason that if a person sins
he truly repents he asks for forgiveness
stop what he's doing agree it is wrong
never does it again Allah will surely
forgive him but here your question is
that if I do good deeds and I ask Allah
to forgive el nowhere does Allah say
that Allah will fulfill all your duas if
would have repented to Allah and says
he's sorry, he'll never do it again.
Inshallah, Allah will forgive him. But
Allah knows he's not going to do that.
We know that. So where is the question?
And you saying that you do good deeds
and ask Allah to forgive. Nowhere does
Allah say that he's going to believe in
all your duas. Allah will forgive your
sin. If you truly repent and you
compensate, Allah will forgive. But that
doesn't mean that you do some good deeds
and you ask Allah to forgive you. This
is not there anywhere and this is a
misconception. Hope that answers the
question.